joining us to talk about college
football as we're getting set for a big
college football season here on the Rich
Eisen show is national columnist from
Yahoo Sports Pat 40 how are you Pat I'm
doing well rich happy football to you
happy football season to you - we made
it Pat we made it you know we did know I
know I know you do everything for Yahoo
including college hoops but you know
nothing quite beats the football playing
season
don't you think Pat no it's it's great
you know I mean after a long summer of
you know kind of fiddling through the
minutiae of baseball season it is at the
beginning of college football season
feels like a big celebration I've always
said that the beginning of college
football in the end of college
basketball or as good as it gets I think
so let's get into this
the Alabama Florida State game how do
you see this one playing out and it's so
difficult to I guess to try and make
heads or tails of these games because
there is no preseason there are no
scrimmages to check out
it's just kick it off and let's see how
these kids do what do you think about
Florida State and Alabama Pat it should
be a slobberknocker you know I mean I
there could be a ton of talent on both
sides of the ball you know Alabama I
think is going to be an improved
offensive team and probably not as good
a defensive team as we saw last you're
hard to be as good as they were
defensively up until at least they
played Clemson but they lost a lot of
guys to the NFL off that defense they
were younger on that side have had a
couple of personnel issues as well here
in pre-season so you know I expect
Florida State to actually be able to
move the ball and then do some scoring
but I don't know whether Florida State
will be able to stop Alabama you know I
think it's going to be a relatively high
scoring game and it should be a really
good one I it's hard to pick against
Alabama they're always ready when the
season starts but it should be a very
close contest
what about jaylen hurts is he a Heisman
contender for you this year yeah you
know I mean I'm going to be a little bit
wait you see on his passing but I
expected to be improved you know the end
of last year they really didn't trust
him to throw much and they certainly
didn't want him throwing over the middle
of the field because i concerned he was
going to turn
all over but you know I think it's an
offseason to work on it he's got a new
coordinator you know Lane Kiffin is gone
everybody Bowl is in I heard about I
heard about that I heard about that
there's always some news where Lane
Kiffin goes and right but I expect Hertz
to be to be much improved as a passer
and still be a very dangerous runner
okay so they are by all measures and
metrics the undisputed favorite going
into the season again who do you think
has the best chance to knock off Alabama
this year Pat you know I think I think
Ohio State's gonna be really good
they're gonna have an incredibly good
defense and they've got a a real veteran
leader in in JT Barrett on the offensive
side they their passing game should be
improved I expect them to be a lot
better with Kevin Wilson as the
coordinator there
I think USC loved the way obviously they
finished the year in the Rose Bowl there
and I think that they're they're set up
for a big season with Sam Donald as a as
maybe the Heisman front-runner at this
point I like I think Oklahoma State is a
team to watch in the big 12
you know I think they talk about
firepower on offense they should really
be able to ring it up there and if they
patch some holes in defense Glenn
Spencer's a very good coordinator
underrated there I think they can win
the big 12 yeah and they've got Tulsa
tomorrow night when Ohio State takes on
Indiana as well any possibility of an
upset and either of those games do you
think well I I'm going actually the Ohio
State Indiana game and I don't expect an
upset there I think you know Ohio
State's I think a much better team than
Indiana and with Kevin Wilson what a
story he was fired and Indiana as the
head coach there last year
Urban Meyer lets him run it up he's
gonna run it up on Indiana we'll see if
they're capable of that and then you
know I think Tulsa pulse is really good
and fill in Montgomery's a real coke on
the rise there I don't think that will
be an easy game for Oklahoma State but I
still think the Cowboys are are too good
for him
well in terms of you know we mentioned
Kevin Wilson with Indiana if he was as
horrible to the
kids in Indiana as Indiana said he was
and fired him wouldn't you think Indiana
would want to run it up on on Ohio State
best they can tomorrow
sure but I don't anticipate them being
able to do that I'm sure they would love
to run it up on Ohio State right being
able to were two different things right
pat forty joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show so did you see that Jim
Harbaugh and Michigan finally did put
out their roster for everybody to check
out today did you sell well oh yeah
great we've moved on from from the 2016
roster here just in time so III know a
depth chart would be far too much to ask
but at least now we know who's on the
team well I mean he's not I don't think
we're gonna see depth chart but he's in
Florida also playing coy with the who's
playing quarterback there or are they
really gonna play three quarterbacks
against Michigan onside I don't think
they're gonna play three you know they
they are they are they're holding their
their hand they're close to the vest
I understand why obviously you know
Malik Zaire is a known commodity Luke
del rio's a known commodity but a
different one than Malik Zaire and then
they've got the freshman Felipe Franks
who hasn't played in college yet so I
you know there's there's a probably good
reason for them to keep them guessing
because their offense could look
significantly different depending on
which of those three actually is out
there taking the first snaps so how do
you how do you see Michigan and Florida
handling one another on Saturday Pat
well you know Florida's got a major
self-inflicted problem because they've
got seven players suspended including
their best receiver Antonio Callaway so
you know they they're in a difficult
position there I mean Michigan's
replacing a ton of guys from last year's
team I mean you know that was a really
veteran team and other than Wilton
Speight there's not a lot coming back at
least in terms of real veteran guys
where Sean Gary's going to be a
superstar on defense but he's just
starting a sophomore year and there's a
lot of holes to fill on that side of the
ball so III would give a slight edge to
Michigan but but there's a lot of
unknowns going into that game Pat forty
of Yahoo Sports joining us here and the
Rich Eisen show ask him the poll
question Chris Brockman that's been
sitting out there for an hour and
usually when we ask this it's the old
lightning-rod conversation go for it
it's the best conference in college
football Pat ACC Big Ten big 12 pac-12
SEC what do you say
top to bottom I'm gonna still say the
SEC even though it looks like Alabama
and a bunch of schmoes do it agree but
the schmoes are pretty good so I'm gonna
give the SEC a narrow edge the you know
the ACC had that had the the best season
that's ever had last year that national
champion they had an Orange Bowl
champion they had a Heisman Trophy
winner but I'm not sure that League
top-to-bottom is as deep as the SEC is
well I mean would you not agree Pat that
there is in a southeast bias though when
it comes to college football in our in
our industry would you know but I think
that was that was import generated by
winning seven straight national champ
that's putting the putting the money
where the mouth is there but yeah
there's probably been a little bit too
much of a hangover from that of people
you know just kind of automatically
ascribing the SEC is the bulletproof
status you know I certainly don't think
that applies anymore again I say you
they are the best league but not head
and shoulders the best which I think
they were for a lot of years well I mean
it's five years god now that's
seven-year run yeah I mean we've moved
on I mean of the ACC's won a couple of
titles the the Big Ten Ohio State won
one and you know I think that it's it's
different times and I look actually at
the coaches in the SEC and I say who is
the second best coach behind Nick Saban
I think there's a real gap there so give
me a team that that nobody's talking
about that might because that always
happens that winds up in the Final Four
give me one that can go on and run here
and wind up in the Final Four that few
people have on there's their radar
screen
this yellow mistake for that as far as
another kind of surprise team maybe not
going to the Final Four but going to the
Big Ten championship game I like
northwestern to win the West I've got to
go at Wisconsin they've got to go at
Nebraska but two years ago they went to
those places in won both games they've
got a real experienced team they've got
a great running back in Justin Jackson
they've got an improving
Mack in Clayton foursome and a lot of
good players on defense so I like that
Fitzgerald ok so then who do you think
they play against in the in the Big Ten
championship game with Penn State
looking as strong as they as they did at
the end of last year yeah and you've got
Michigan Ohio State all in that same
division what do you got for me yeah you
know I mean I think I think it's going
to be a great battle between Ohio State
and Penn State to win the East and I
I'll take Ohio State there I just I
think that they get Penn State in
Columbus this year and it is look at
Penn State's gonna be really good again
but they they they had a lot of comeback
victories they had some close wins and I
think that they they were they were good
but they were also pretty fortunate and
sometimes it's hard to have that kind of
fortune two years in a row alright Pat
thanks for the knowledge we'll chat down
a line I can't have the happy football
season right back at you this is it
we're finally here
we made it thank you Richard you go
that's Pat forty of Yahoo Sports the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches